[Musik]
ein wunderschöner Morgen er wartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen
skyblockwelt meine Damen und Herren
diesen Satz habe ich tatsächlich seit
mittlerweile mehr als einem Monat nicht
mehr gesagt und ich werde euch auch
gleich sagen woran das gelegen hat und
ich werde euch auch gleich erklären
warum im Titel steht dass ich heute
cheaten werde ihr wisst ja dass ich
eigentlich der ist einfach gerade
innerhalb von einer Millisekunde wieder
nachgewachsen ne ihr wisst ja dass ich
eigentlich ein sehr großer Minecraft
Romantiker bin und boah hier ist auch
einiges gewachsen ne man merkt auf jeden
Fall dass ich eine lange Zeit nicht mehr
hier in der Map war ich will doch gar
nicht wissen was dahin Monster angesporn
ist geht's auf jeden Fall auch
ordentlich ab gehen wir auch gleich hin
ich bin in Minecraft Romantiker wollte
ich kurz sagen ich hasse cheaten nicht
nur bei Minecraft sondern auch bei
anderen Spielen wie GTA oder keine
Ahnung was wir spielen man auch so
standardmäßig eigentlich häufig mal
Cheats eingeben weil ich finde es macht
den Spaß kaputt noch nie war es so dass
man nach einem Cheat gesagt hat ey macht
mir jetzt wirklich viel mehr Spaß man
hat immer noch mal kurz gemacht und dann
hatte man eine Viertelstunde Spaß dann
war es wieder vorbei und das ist der
Grund warum ich auch eigentlich in
Minecraft dagegen bin zu cheaten und
eher ein Freund bekommen ich mache eine
timelapse wie ich Steine abbaue anstatt
dass ich da komme ich cheate mir Steine
allerdings ist es heute an der Zeit das
habe ich auch schon vor einigen Folgen
angekündigt dass ich diesen ganzen
popelkrams hier an das kann man es
wirklich nicht nennen äh abbauen werde
im Creative Mode also dass ich in
minecraft rumfliegen kann es ist
tatsächlich sogar das eigentlich wenn
man mal darüber nachdenkt das komplette
Gegenteil von einem Cheat denn ich werde
halt diese ganzen Blöcke nicht kriegen
wenn ich die abbaue kriege ich die
eventuell weil die mir dann ins Inventar
fallen wenn ich abbauen und dann hier so
wieder rüber nach Hause laufe durch den
Cheat gehen die quasi alle verloren aber
das ist mir egal also ich ziehe mir
keine item sondern wir sparen einfach
Zeit dadurch dass ich nicht das wird
locker eine Stunde dauern ja alles
einzeln abzubauen ich habe auch nur
Steinwerkzeuge und nicht Diamant Sachen
oder so das wird echt extrem in den
Rahmen sprengen deswegen heute werden
wir auf jeden Fall am Ende der Folge
cheaten bevor wir das allerdings tun
werden wir dort hinten hingehen
und den Leuten da hinten mein Besuch
abstatten
dafür brauche ich allerdings
bruchsteinstufen und dafür brauchen wir
erstmal eine ganz kurze timelapse
[Musik]
so meine Damen und Herren ein
wunderschöner neuer Morgen erwartet uns
hier ich lass das hier unten mal weiter
wachsen denn ich möchte jetzt ein
bisschen vorankommen und wir sprinten
jetzt mal nach dorthin ich habe mir
genügend bruchsteinstufen gemacht
insgesamt haben wir ein zwei drei vier
fünf sechs sechs
insgesamt das sollte auf jeden Fall
ausreichen und dann schauen wir doch mal
was da hinten die Festung so für uns zu
bieten da bzw eine Festung ist es ja gar
nicht sehr so ein Außenposten in
Minecraft Sprache glaube ich das ist der
richtige Begriff während ich dort
allerdings hinlaufen habe ich euch die
Teilnehmer schon beendet denn ich habe
eine kleine Sache
die ich euch fragen möchte und ich weiß
es ist mein YouTube-Kanal und
schlussendlich wenn ich Bock hätte
könnte ich jetzt auch sagen komm ich mal
wieder drei vier Wochen Minecraft
Skyblock Pause das lag nicht am Projekt
und das ist mir keinen Spaß mehr macht
sondern weil ich generell einfach gesagt
habe ja schon im Podcast auch nach
Silvester wird erstmal ein paar Wochen
bisschen ruhiger bei mir sein mit
YouTube weil ich einfach so ein bisschen
chillen möchte ich möchte ein bisschen
Zeit mit Freunden verbringen aber mir
auch Gedanken machen was ich in dem
neuen Jahr so ein bisschen machen möchte
im Jahr 2023 haben wir mittlerweile
schon nicht nur auf Youtube sondern
generell auf Social Media und habe mir
dann halt gedacht komm mache ich das
ganze mal in der Januar Zeit der Januar
ist ja meine Ansicht nach immer so der
Mondtag des Jahres deswegen schaffe ich
das
ich bin krass kann ich mal noch mal
nicht mal wieder mal
bin ich irre bin ich lebenswütig ich
habe voll viele Sachen dabei der Baum
hier sollte jetzt auf jeden Fall langsam
mal die spawnen also die Laubblätter
sollten dort verschwinden das ist ja
immer leider so weil unsere Insel wo wir
das ist ein Grafikfehler hier ganz kurz
den haben wir auch manchmal leider am
Start aufgrund des shaders allerdings
ähm es ist ja so dass meine Insel wo ich
mein Haus Häuschen habe jetzt in
Skyblock und die Monster fahren und so
das ist zu weit entfernt so dass die
Chunks geladen werden wo sich hier
beispielsweise der Baum befunden hat
deswegen waren die Blätter da die ganze
Zeit noch da aber wenn wir nachher den
geben am Ende der Episode dann müsste
auf jeden Fall dran bleiben dann werden
wir das auch alles wegmachen damit alles
wieder schön und clean aussehen das ist
mir immer sehr wichtig in Minecraft
allerdings habe ich ja gerade schon
angekündigt ich möchte eine kleine Sache
sagen ein Stückchen immer noch weiter
hier und zwar habe ich eine kleine Sache
mir überlegt bzw auch von euch in einem
Twitch Livestream von mir ich hatte dort
Laser Luca und habe jetzt in letzter
Zeit ein bisschen häufiger livestreamt
und das auch weiter fortführen ich habe
richtig Bock drauf jetzt habe ich in
Köln eine vernünftige Internetleitung
vernünftigen PC und kann das alles
vernünftig machen
da haben wir viele von euch gesagt Luca
was hältst du eigentlich davon wenn
Minecraft Skyblock einen Livestream
Event wird also dass ich beispielsweise
die Folgen hier nicht mehr so jetzt hier
einfach aufnehme und äh dann schneide
und hochlade sondern dass ich im Stream
auf
twitch.tv/laserdrucker müsste mir alle
Folgen des kostenlos ähm dass ich dort
einfach Minecraft Skyblock Spiele und
das hat nur Vorteile meiner Ansicht nach
ihr habt mich da echt krass von
überzeugt im Livestream Chat als ich da
vor ein paar Tagen Minecraft mit Sandra
gespielt habe live und zwar kann ich
live auf euer Feedback eingehen ich habe
direkt das äh eine direkte Kommunikation
mit euch das heißt wenn ich Fragen habe
wie z.B ey wie kann ich mein Portal da
hinten anzünden ich habe ja kein
Feuerzeug das muss man dann irgendwie
mit Lava machen glaube ich dann könnt
ihr mir direkt schreiben hey Luca guck
mal du mussten Holzblock nehmen daneben
stellen und dann Lava drauf dann habe
ich direkt eine Lösung und es ist dann
nicht so wie ey Leute wie soll ich das
machen mit der Monster fahren wie soll
ich das reparieren da muss ich warten
bis die Folge online ist muss mir eure
Kommentare durchlesen muss ihr müsst da
jemand vielleicht eine Lösung hat und
dann erst im neuen Video kann nichts
anwenden sondern da kann ich direkt
quasi auf den Chat drauf eingehen und
Lösungen direkt implementieren in meine
Skyblock Welt das ist ein großer Vorteil
und es würde sich für euch auch nichts
dran ändern denn das Projekt würde halt
auf Twitch beim Twitch Account Laser
Luca laufen ich würde das dort live
streamen beispielsweise morgen direkt um
18 Uhr wenn ihr Bock habt
und dann würde ich die Highlights davon
trotzdem auf dem Kanal hier hochladen
das heißt ihr könnt einerseits im Stream
mit dabei sein wenn ich live bin morgen
um 18 Uhr würde ich das beispielsweise
machen das würde ich schaffen und ihr
könnt euch den Stream auch noch mal im
Nachhinein auf meinem Twitch Account
angucken auf Laser Luca das heißt wenn
ihr beim Stream morgen nicht dabei sein
können könnt ihr trotzdem am Samstag
oder am Sonntag oder in drei Jahren
sagen hey ich habe das verpasst ich
würde mich gerne noch mal angucken oder
ihr könnt euch dann einfach das Stream
Highlight best of auf meinem
YouTube-Kanal anschauen also es gibt
ganz ganz viele Möglichkeiten und es hat
eigentlich nur Vorteile deswegen findet
ihr einfach mal unten in Kommentare man
kann leider nicht mehr über diese
Infokarte Funktion hier oben in der Ecke
so eine Umfrage machen das hat YouTube
irgendwie weggemacht ich habe das
richtig oft benutzt ich war das richtig
cool das Feature aber ihr findet jetzt
unten in die Kommentaren deswegen schaut
da mal rein zwei Kommentare von mir
einmal Twitch Livestream ja und einmal
Twitch Livestreams nein geht bitte dem
Kommentar einen Daumen Hoch den ihr halt
möchtet ihr könnt auch dem anderen
Kommentar dann Daumen Runter geben wie
ihr wollt und dann schaue ich einfach
mal das ist sehr weit oben da muss ich
oh was ist denn das ist doch so Dinger
hier wieder am rumfliegen da haben wir
auf jeden Fall oh die dürfen mich auf
jeden Fall nicht runterschießen dann
muss ich echt aufpassen naja lange Rede
kurzer Sinn
macht das mal bitte in den Kommentaren
stimmt da mal bitte ab da können wir
dann schauen ob ihr kann nicht anschauen
ob ihr da Bock drauf habt oder nicht und
dann äh oder sieht mich schon
[Musik]
oh
was mache ich denn jetzt ich glaube
am sinnvollsten ist es
wenn ich mir Leitern crafte
vielleicht insgesamt so
15 Stück ne kann ich gar nicht 12
sollten auch erstmal ausreichend hoffe
ich
dann baue ich mich hier
einfach hoch mit Leitern
das ist glaube ich das sinnvollste
wahrscheinlich weil er doch noch ein
Stückchen weit weg ist ich habe Angst
hier runter zu fallen ich habe auch kein
Wasser immer mit aber so ein MLG
wassersprung würde ich glaube ich eh
nicht hinkriegen ich bin auf jeden Fall
schon auf der Höhe das habe ich ja gar
nicht gedacht dass ich ja darunter
fallen kann wenn die mich abschießen
da muss ich jetzt aber echt ich werde
vielleicht erstmal da vorne hingehen
oder wie soll ich mich dahin bauen ich
weiß es gerade gar nicht wie gehe ich
denn da am besten vor
weil wenn die einmal schießen völlig
hier runter
oh Gott oh Gott am besten vielleicht
sogar von oben da drauf
[Musik]
boah das ist aber auch nicht sinnvoll
weil dann ich habe jetzt nicht genügend
Leiter mit an das habe ich nicht gedacht
also das ganze Twitch Livestream Thema
jetzt mal aus dem vor ich habe es ja
breit und
so gut es geht erklärt
ihr habt auf jeden Fall in den
Kommentaren die Möglichkeit
abzustimmen also macht das gerne mal
ich kann die auch einfach attackieren
fällt mir gerade auf oh Gott guck mal
die schubsen sich automatisch von
alleine runter da ein bisschen
ja die fallen da runter
das ist sehr gut für uns oh Gott komm da
viele an
oh ich habe echt Schiss dass sie mich
hier runter schießen ich habe auch nur
64 Pfeile hätte ich vielleicht doch noch
mal zu Monster Farm hingehen müssen
oh Gott oh Gott meinte ich kann mich
nach da unten bauen weil theoretisch
wenn ich von oben schießen
mein Schwert ist auch fast kaputt ich
Idiot ey oh ich habe aber zum Glück
alles schwer zu craften eben boah da
habe ich ja gar nichts dran gedacht ich
hätte doch vielleicht mal vernünftig
noch im Bett mitnehmen sollen ey Gott
ich bin ja so ein Idiot die da vorne
guckt mich alle an der sind schon wieder
neu gebaut und dann wenn ich den töte
haben Überfall am Start ne aber ich habe
jetzt zum Glück kein Villager das heißt
wenn warte mal wenn der jetzt
runterfällt müsste ja glaube ich gleich
die Benachrichtigung kommen dass ich
irgendwie ein Überfall gestartet habe
oder das wird halt im Inventar angezeigt
die sind alle tot ne es wird noch nicht
angezeigt ich riskiere es jetzt einfach
mal glaube ich ich bau mich jetzt
einfach mal rüber
[Musik]
du scheiße
oh mein Gott
Alter sind das viele
die kommen aber nicht hoch
die sind tot ich gehe mal direkt nach
oben alle töten schnell Essen
sind wir hier schon oben aber hier ist
keiner hier ist irgendwie keiner wo sind
die noch was haben wir hier wir haben
Kartoffeln wir haben einen Armbrust wir
haben einen
gefurzt
[Musik]
der furzt ins Rohr
ey krass ne
wie weit das Weg ist guck mal wir sind
den ganzen Weg gelaufen hierüber wie
lange haben wir uns gebaut und dann hier
hin
und es sieht echt so mini aus unsere
kleine Welt da hinten ich liebe
Minecraft wirklich kann sich auf genug
sagen ich baue jetzt einfach mal die
Kiste hier ab dann haben wir direkt die
ganzen Items hier am Start ich weiß
nicht ob ich hier sonst noch irgendwie
was brauche ich will dir nichts abbauen
weil wir das ja alles im Cheat Mode
gleich machen da unten gehen wir gleich
auf jeden Fall auch noch hin aber ich
glaube wir haben die Leute alle besiegt
und ihr sollte niemand mehr am Start
sein das heißt wir können theoretisch
schon mal eben ein Stockwerk tiefer
gehen hier ist auch noch was
[Musik]
ich höre noch was die können wir mit
Scheren abbauen aber wir haben noch kein
Eisen oh
Vollidioten
ich höre immer noch was
wo ist das
[Musik]
okay der ist auch weg
wir haben es
ich höre nichts mehr das Blöde ist nur
dass es jetzt regnet und das heißt es
können Monster spawnen da müssen wir
darauf aufpassen dass jetzt nicht noch
irgendwie Skelette kommen oder so ich
werde mich jetzt mal da vorne erstmal
rüber bauen um die Wolle zu holen die
wir von da vorne benötigen oh mein Gott
[Musik]
das ist ja wieder Sonne stressige
Episode Alter da habe ich drei Wochen
Pause gemacht von Skyblock komme zurück
und alle haben was gegen mich alle
hetzen alle greifen mich an das ist doch
nicht Wahr Leute
sogar das Wetter hasst mich ah die Wolle
hast mich auch alles geht schief wieder
Alter dieses blöde Gewitter wir müssen
echt zurück und schlafen ich mein Bett
mitgenommen aber ich meine wenigstens
haben wir jetzt die Wolle ihr könnt mir
gerne mal in die Kommentare schreiben
wenn ich jetzt live er könntet ihr mir
halt direkt sagen hey Luca macht so und
so hier mit der Wolle dann ist sinnvoll
aber das ist ja gerade leider nicht live
so noch die beiden hier dann haben das
Zack und der da vorne noch
ich habe auch nur noch die Hälfte meiner
Pfeile die kommen immer wieder ne
Zäune brauche ich nicht hier vorne
schon wieder irgendwelche Sounds
da vorne steht wieder einer wir müssen
hier auf ihrem hier ist noch einer wir
müssen ja auf jeden Fall fix weg ich
habe jetzt auch nicht unendlich Essen
mit ich Idiot ich habe noch so viele
pilzsuppen habe das aber gar nicht
irgendwie auf dem Schirm gehabt dass ich
dir mitnehmen ich habe dir nur für die
Challenge was ich ja schon wieder
irgendwie rum grillen
[Musik]
immer weiter
ich weiß auch ehrlich gesagt nicht was
das für Dinger da drin sind ne
ich höre die ganze Zeit zum Grummeln von
diesen Viechern
schreibt immer bitte unten in die
Kommentare oh mein Gott
schreibt mir mal bitte unten in die
Kommentare was das für Teile sind und
wofür ich die benötige
weil ich habe das noch nie gesehen in
Minecraft
so komische blaue Fliege Dinge an die
Sache ist jetzt allerdings wir müssen
dann ja wahrscheinlich safe noch mal die
hin und über diesen ganzen Weg laufen
das heißt cheaten heute wird eh keinen
Sinn ergeben außer für den hinteren
Bereich und das ist allerdings auch
erstmal tatsächlich genau das was ich
jetzt machen werde denn ich möchte auf
jeden Fall in der heutigen Episode
cheaten ich habe den Titel geschrieben
und mich stört es
nein Leute trymacs hier nein nein nein
[Musik]
die können hier den Creeper spawnen
ich habe das doch extra auf diese halbe
Blockstufe gebaut das kann doch nicht
sein dass sie jetzt Creeper spawnen
ey Leute ich kacke ja komplett ab damit
verfolgt mich hinter mir auch noch
dieser Typ mit der Armbrust wirklich ey
ich bin wieder auf eure Tipps angewiesen
beziehungsweise wenn ihr sagt ja Bock
auf Livestream Skyblock mit Luca morgen
um 18 Uhr dann schaut in die Kommentare
gebt einen Daumen Hoch bei dem Kommentar
Twitch Livestreams ja dann werden wir
das morgen machen ich sprinte jetzt
erstmal nach Hause die Sache ist auch
das wollte ich vorhin schon sagen ich
wollte dieses Video eigentlich schon
gestern hochladen ich habe gesagt
eigentlich in meinem letzten Livestream
das am Mittwoch mit Luca kommt die Sache
ist allerdings dass ich mir gestern
während der Aufnahme kam Kumpel zu mir
wollte chillen und ich habe den dann
halt hochgelassen während der Aufnahme
ihm die Tür aufgemacht wollte ihn
erschrecken und bin mit meinem Kopf
gegen den Türrahmen gesprungen so dass
ich eine Platzwunde hatte ich habe auch
die Aufnahme lief ja deswegen ich habe
auch die Sounds davon nicht Spielzeug
immer ab
Alter
kam gerade an und ich wollte eine
überraschen und bin gegen die Tür aus
Versehen gesprungen gegen den Türrahmen
und jetzt habe ich einen Cut oben an
meinem Kopf und es blutet und ich Kühler
schon die ganze ich will es euch nicht
zeigen jetzt kommt ein Krankenwagen ich
konnte logischerweise gestern die
Aufnahme nach dieser Platz wurden
Geschichte mit Krankenhaus und planen
nicht mehr fortsetzen und hatte zum
Glück noch eine Backup Version von
meiner Skyblock mit Luca Welt so dass
ich das jetzt heute quasi neu starten
konnte diese Folge allerdings ähm ja
muss ich dementsprechend die Folge auf
heute verschieben ich gehe jetzt erstmal
ganz kurz hier schlafen ich will
natürlich hinter einem zu machen so dass
der Regen weg ist und dass wir Tag haben
und dass wir endlich
auch mal wieder entspannte Musik hier am
Start haben also und damit die Musik am
Start meine Damen und Herren ich laufe
auch mal eben kurz zum Monster fahren
auch hier ist gar nicht so viele Idiot
das hätte ich zu Beginn der Folge glaube
ich machen müssen weil dann noch relativ
viel hier stand aber dadurch dass der
Junkie nicht mehr geladen hatte weil ich
ja dort hinten war aber ich habe mich
auch wieder glücklich davor gebaut nee
weil ich da hinten war hier leider
keiner erzähl kein Monster gesponnen
schaut euch mal was hier jetzt schon
wieder abgeht allein naja gut wir wollen
noch mal zum Ende kommen die Folge schon
wieder sehr sehr lang sorry dass sie
gesagt dann gestern dieses Video hier
nicht kam sondern heute ich glaube ihr
könnt allerdings verstehen ich lag halt
im Krankenhaus musste geklebt werden ich
will euch keine Fotos einblenden wie das
aussehen damit das Video gesperrt aber
alles voll mit Blut mein ganzer Kopf war
chillig ja Leute ich äh versetze mich
jetzt tatsächlich zum allerersten Mal
seit Minecraft Staffel 1 in den game
mode created
habe ich keine Rechte auf meine eigenen
Welt okay ich habe gerade mal gegoogelt
man musste wohl die lan-welt öffnen
jetzt bin ich creative Mod okay ihr seht
schon meine Herzen sind weg ich kann
fliegen über meine Welt ich kann hoch
fliegen ich kann runter fliegen und wenn
ich irgendwas zerstöre geht das genau in
diesem Moment das heißt ich habe keine
Abbauzeiten von daher
ich cheate in Skyblock mit Luca meine
Damen und Herren kurze Tablets wie ich
hier alles ganz fix wegbaue
ich habe eine coole Idee drei zwei
1 Baum junge das erste TNT wurde
gezündet und es explodiert
wieso funktioniert das nicht
meine Damen und Herren funktioniert wir
cheaten in Skyblock mit Luca und machen
was
[Musik]
warum bleiben deine Sachen übrig
Mann ich hatte so eine coole Idee dass
wir alles in die Luft springen jetzt ist
gar nicht so geworden wie ich wollte
jetzt muss ich das endlich nur noch mehr
Blöcke abbauen eine Stunde später so
meine Damen und Herren die letzten
Blöcke habe ich jetzt mal abgebaut hier
vorne ist nichts mehr und der ganz
hinten seht ihr auch schon richtig gar
nichts mehr diesen komischen
kristallwürfel da Ball da hinten habe
ich abgebaut ich habe da vorne die
Inseln abgebaut und auch meinen Weg
runter leider musste ich jetzt leider ja
wie gesagt noch mehr abbauen weil die
TNT ist ja nicht so richtig gezündet
haben auf den halbstufen jedoch habe ich
jetzt den Weg nach dahinten einfach mal
genauso wie ich den vorhin gebaut habe
da gelassen weil dann müssen wir
vielleicht noch mal hin dann würde ich
vielleicht noch mal cheaten und das dann
auch noch mal weg machen jedoch habe ich
mir auch ein Feuerzeug geholt für das
TNT das wird natürlich auch
weggeschmissen also einmal zack ich gehe
wieder in den Gamemode survival und ihr
seht schon ich habe mir keine extra
Sachen irgendwie geholt das waren genau
die Sachen die ich vorher auch hatte und
da die Sonne auch schon wieder untergeht
würde ich an der Stelle tatsächlich das
heutige Video auch beenden ich erstmal
fix aber eben eine Kartoffel und dass
ich hier meine Hunger behalten komplett
auffüllen kann ich glaube man kann
Kartoffeln auch braten dann gehen wir
noch mal ein bisschen mehr Hunger zurück
allerdings ja meine Damen und Herren war
das die Cheat Episode ich habe jetzt
endlich mal hier so ein bisschen ein
schöneren Ausblick da vorne müsste ich
nachher noch einen Zaun dran setzen das
mache ich dann auch in der nächsten
Episode einfach mal äh nee mache ich
jetzt
ihr kennt mich
dann wird das jetzt auch fertig gemacht
vernünftig so zack dann können wir auch
mal kurz abbauen so der hier rein
[Musik]
ich habe Eisen
sehe ich gerade ein Eisen machen wird
auf jeden Fall gedroppt das ist sehr
sehr gut und die ganzen Sachen sortiere
mal fix
das auch
Haken habe ich okay chillig Armbrust
kann ich mal hier reinpacken Stock
brauche ich nicht
so viele kann Powder hier
und hier vorne noch die Seite
dann haben wir es danke euch fürs
zuschauen sorry dass ich so verklatscht
auch sehr aber ich darf jetzt eine Woche
meine Haare nicht waschen wegen der
Platzwunde auf dem Kopf wie gesagt
schaut mal in die Kommentare
hinsichtlich Twitch Livestreams wenn ihr
da Bock drauf habt bin ich morgen um 18
Uhr live folgt mir dort ich heiße Laser
Luca genauso wie auch auf Instagram
tiktok und überall deswegen habe ich die
Ciao haut rein
[Musik]